an alternative to a potentially deadly
chemical found in common paint strippers
faces hurdles to reach consumers we
reported last month on the deaths of
dozens of people who use methylene
chloride last month the EPA indefinitely
postponed a ban on that chemical
proposed by the Obama administration and
a warner spoke to researchers who
developed what they call a less harmful
product ana good morning good morning
bianna researchers say if the industry
won't come up with a safer product they
will while activists push for retailers
to take the existing methylene chloride
based products out of their stores to
protect consumers the science is clear
that these chemicals are dangerous
Mike shade runs the mind the store
consumer campaign petitioning retailers
to take paint strippers containing the
toxic chemical methylene chloride off
the shelves they're literally deadly for
workers and consumers workers like Wendy
Hartley's 21 year old son Kevin found
unconscious by an older brother you know
he's I'm sorry mom I did everything that
I could do and I couldn't save him
Hartley like dozens of others died in an
entirely preventable accident overcome
by methylene chloride fumes in the paint
stripper he was using while on the job
refinishing a bathtub in April last year
manufacturers acknowledged the dangers
but say there are no good substitutes
for methylene chloride paint strippers
industry lobbyists Fager all we think
it's very unfortunate that anyone has
died
as a result of the product but there is
a need for the product but researchers
in Massachusetts say that answer isn't
good enough it's one of the most toxic
and dangerous chemicals that anyone is
using today professor Michael Ellen
Becker directs a program at the
University of Massachusetts Lowell that
works to come up with alternatives to
highly toxic chemicals his team working
with students came up with an
alternative paint stripping chemical
your version works just as well as
methylene chloride just as quickly yes
so our substitute costs about the same a
little bit more than methylene chloride
it works and it's safer research manager
Greg morose showed us we've got
you read latex topcoats on a test board
painted with several coats and baked at
high temperatures to simulate real-life
conditions each solvent is applied to a
different circle see look at that the
methylene chloride based strippers
bubble up the paint making it easy to
remove and the team's new solvent that
worked they say they did it by sorting
through a database of existing much less
toxic solvents then came up with a new
combination they say works just as well
a project that took them less than a
year we just looked at what was
available put them together in a new way
and came up with a much safer solution
my hopes is that this gets on the
shelves of retailers as soon as possible
it's ready to go
that might seem simple but they're
already encountering opposition from at
least one major methylene chloride
products manufacturer company WM Bar
argued to the EPA that the university's
new solvent could have its own problems
of flammability and toxicity and that
bar zone tests of the combination prove
it doesn't work well enough but they had
the wrong ratio so of course it wouldn't
work so why do you think they did that
well there's a lot of inertia to you
know maintain the continued use of
methylene chloride has been used for 70
years in products that's their message
that's their mantra so if someone comes
along who's outside of the industry like
we are and says now here's a perfectly
good alternative their immediate
responses can't be true so you're out to
prove them wrong exactly that's what
we're doing so what about those claims
from the manufacturer the university
researchers told us they're conducting
further tests to prove that it is much
less hazardous their combination and
they say that's the point of their
research to come up with alternatives
that don't carry the same risks like
death the industry told us it thinks new
warning labels it's proposing can be
effective in preventing further deaths
from these products but many of the
experts and the researchers that we
talked to said that the problem is
consumers and workers don't read those
labels don't pay attention to them or
they're used to having it on the shelves
to fail about the fine print that so
many people don't read yeah and breaking
that habit is hard it is the product
that a lot of people use right so we'll
see maybe
on the shelf they've got a startup
company that's interested in it and
we'll see what happens
all right it's a good news story at the
end of the day Anna thanks